and i also want to again to not to jump
around too much but the fact that you're
afraid of antique furniture i think is
the greatest is that that's a real thing
yeah it's a not afraid of it as much
there's a definite phobia I'm creeped
out by it and not all of it it's just
certain things like for instance I some
of my phobias I don't understand why
everybody doesn't have it dear I mean
it's like you know those old wheelchairs
you'd see back in like the 1920s and
stuff yeah yeah kind of wicker on the
good stuff you know who wouldn't be
creeped out by that thing but it's just
interesting from a guy like you know
years ago you were notorious for having
you know blood locket with your with
your wife at the time right and then to
go forward and be like well here's what
creeps me out cuz to a lot of no that's
that was like oh these are the creepy
people over here and you're like no no
no I don't like [ __ ] wicker
wheelchairs yeah they don't creep me out
I find them a little I but they don't
creep me out and make me uncomfortable
like where's my castle you know like to
go in a castle with all the mildew and
the moss on the wall those big old
creepy chairs with the velvet on him and
stuff I couldn't eat around that is it
about ghosts and people being dead no
it's it's it's like a sling Rose injure
me yeah it's like guys can you clean off
a place for me to eat here I can't do
this and I just creeps me out cuz
there's no reason to hold onto furniture
for that buy some new furniture yeah cuz
that doesn't have all the [ __ ] on it
that's been piling up there for years
yeah that's so it has nothing to do with
the fact that there have been dead
people on there above it's just cuz it's
so old I mean let's say I go into a rag
shop and I see a really great I don't
know deep purple shirt yeah that's from
the day yeah and it's on a rack with a
bunch of other dusty old shirts and I
buy it I go home and I wash the thing up
you know three or four times you doing
yeah I'm not gonna wear that thing you
know Roger used to wear it you know and
Roger like no telling you got to see you
don't like gyros are you do you a
handshake are you know like chickens
I'll shake hands but then I immediately
use the purity oh yeah yeah is it's a
understand certain phobias like heights
I'm afraid of heights and I get why
people be claustrophobic
but then there's some of the other ones
I find her you know you're not a Jeremy
guys know I probably wish I was you I'd
wear condoms yeah about to say your
personal well to be deeply affected you
and Jeremy guy exactly no you know it's
weird because you know when you sign
stuff for guys in the streets you know
like I'll autograph people you know yeah
I I have a real problem because I'm a
germaphobe it away and at the same time
I'm codependent so it's like a really
bad deal because just now we came from a
TV show right well I sign all the ones i
can get to you know I sign OH Matt
everything and then I get in the car and
I wiped my hands down and then a couple
other cats to come up on the skateboards
or whatever next to a car cuz you know
in New York in li you get a wife people
really bad yeah you know here you can't
get away right so you're stuck on on a
block there and then three or four cats
show up at the window and you know I'm
gonna do it because I like I said I'm
codependent so I'll roll the window down
I've just I've just used the Purell now
I think the other guys pin I write some
other stuff up and roll the window up
use the Purell and then another cat
shows up instantly and I do his too so I
have to use a lot of lotion you know
yeah he's destroying all that all the
anti-base around the exact